spero che stia bene oggi a volte la vita
non è facile ma sono qui per lei grazie
zia prezzo oggi giochiamo a detroit che
ho avuto in anteprima circa una
settimana fa l'ho già finito per i
cavoli miei ai ringrazio sony che mi ha
dato la limited edition che questa
giocandoci ho visto che il primo
capitolo di questo gioco
secondo me può essere fatto per un video
è fighissimo quindi ragazzi oggi lo
porto per voi perché lo faccio per voi
prossima teoria del gatto di schrodinger
ma te l'ho chiesto finché non decidi
cosa vai l'ostaggio che la sfiga in
brevissimo nel mondo ci sono gli
androidi che sono un tipo dei robot con
delle sembianze umane siamo nel 2038 io
non avrò ancora la patente
che bello avevo già giocato quindi so
già cosa succede
vi si chiama conrad è un androide e deve
sventare un tentativo di omicidio
in questo momento ed è bravo con le
monete mi ripeteva di dirvi una cosa sto
gioco qua va a bivi nel senso che tu
decidi le cose da fare e in base a
quello che decidi cedono
un androide missione dobbiamo dare non
potete farlo ma io sono più vero di lei
signora trova il capitano vabbè ve la
spiego e abili nel senso che in base a
quello che fai
c'è potrebbe andare a finire in modo
diverso semioli gli temi la situazione
sono qua per voi pagate meno state su
facebook li capitano all ecco mi chiamo
quando potremo intervenire ma sono
supporto della terrazza se locale dai
chiodi
sa già che posso scegliere la cosa
chiedergli nome nel deviante conosce il
suo nome non ne ho idea
è importante mi servono informazioni per
stabilire oggi shock emotivo subito
qualche shock emotivo che la gente
senti salvare la bambina è ciò che conta
perciò ci pensi tu a questo android e
oggi pensioni
faccio io tranquillo
e allora
ride
cioè praticamente analizzi le cose che
sherlock e si possono spostare ragazzi
cos'è emorragia del polmone superiore
pneumotorace beh anch'io avrei fatto
questa analisi deceduto
bravo intuizione incredibile
ricostruisci zio io ricostruisco tutto
io posso ti fa vedere come è morto
fighissima starò a ciel android e gli ha
sparato mentre stava al ipad a guardare
i video li fa vigenti di padre stava
stringendo qualcosa la ipad lo vedo che
un ipad
poi ha sparato e l'ipad è caduto rino
andiamo a vedere cosa sta guardando su
come stanno comprando su amazon ipad sta
lì quindi a mio vedere l'ipad made gol
praticamente si stavano per ordinare
stavano per ordinare un altro android e
al suo posto e l'androide sei incazzato
e ha sparato alla famiglia e ha preso in
ostaggio alla bambina che è la figlia di
quello che è appena morto
[Musica]
piano toglietevi che faccio io qua il
poliziotto non siete capaci
vedrete prendi prendi che lascia prendi
sempre utile ci siamo è arrivato il
momento in cui devo sventare il tentato
omicidio
ci penso io stiamo aspettando spariamo
questo pezzo di merda cagato sotto
sapevo già come sarebbe successo mi
tocca gap è uguale non avvicinarsi un
brutto tranquilli nome mica quante
scelte qua io mi chiamo caldo
e tu invece
come ti chiami è il dover che mi hanno
dato sei indietro
val cavargna l'elicottero
stai tranquillo ti prendo io devi
lasciare andare emma
è solo una bambina non c'entra niente
con tutto questo progetto se non a
saltare mi spara non sono così stupido 6
armato
mento no non ho una pistola fumetti so
che hai una pistola
ti sto dicendo la verità sono venuto
disarmato
in colpa guarda cosa hai fatto non sei
progettato per uccidere gli umani la
gente ha bisogno di cure
che si prendessero cura di me che mi
volessero fare
però essere qualcuno
sta perdendo sangue se non lo portiamo
subito in ospedale morirà gli umani
muoiono prima o poi
che importanza se questo muore ora userà
un laccio emostatico
porca vacca tocca a lui ti uccido
e ora non può uccidervi non sono vivo
40 per cento di probabilità di successo
sto provando a fare diversamente da come
l'avevo fatto la prima volta
il guasto 6 difettoso degna c'è un
problema nel tuo software co sistemeremo
e tutto tornerà come prima ho bisogno di
niente funziona perfettamente
ma ho aperto gli occhi ormai non
permetterò più a nessuno di umiliarmi
io
la tenia quello che è fatto è morto
ragazzo facendo tutto l'opposto di
quello che vorrei fare non dipende da te
sono io che raccoglie gioco se io voglio
lei muore
mi hai capito
questo rumore mi sto facendo impazzire
benigni di mandare via quell'elicottero
ragas non facendo tutto il contrario di
quello che vorrei fare solo perché non
ho mai fatto così
io l'ho finita in un certo modo sono la
sua ultima possibilità se la perdi ti
uccideranno lasciò andare l'ostaggio non
hai altro assetto
forti o che maldini a tutti e voglio una
macchina
una volta fuori città la lascerà libera
impossibile degne lascia la ragazza nei
prometto che nessuno ti farà del male
non voglio morire
in verità mai ucciso degli umani niente
impedirà loro di distruggerli e uccidere
suonerà le cose
prendo ordini da tutta la vita
ora tocca a me decidere
non sono proprio queste cose prendi la
veloce vuole ce l'ho fatta non ci credo
a sono cascato anch'io
ah ok
ok strano
pensavo cadesse con la bambina ero
convinto volevo che finisse così non
sono un sadico è per carità però io
l'avevo salvata e mi ero salvato anche
io e mi sembrava troppo banale quindi
volevo che finisse malissimo invece non
è successo
va bene pur facendo tutto al contrario
sono riusciti a salvare la bambina sono
fenomeno no perché ha un filo un sacco
di finalista parte può amori possono
morire tutti un miliardo di cose tipo
sei sette finali sono riuscito a farla
finire comunque bene
e questo e detroit vabbè io ragazzi
penso di poter concludere qua e
finissimo come gioco mi è piaciuto
tantissimo e ringrazio sony però il
mandato la limited edition
spero che video vi sia piaciuto come al
solito sei video è piaciuto questo
momento mi piace anche ai social comino
ad una descrizione sono solo quei siti
schiette e noi ci vediamo
non so il telecomando ma vabbè da
ragazzi
[Musica]